aigo tell us about site titan
semi-definite programming sessions for
polynomial
sniper and stangs organizers so you can
see the topic of my my talking is about
a tidal equations for polynomial
transition why is not specially about
hyperbolic polynomials but however if we
are optimistic we can see hyperbolic
polynomials at the special case I'm
finding them is there we apply okay so
what's the priority well as it's easy
putting on the optimizing is you can see
you there this question so suppose we
have what force of a minimize effects
say that this is one of the objective
and we have the contents why you like we
might have both I mean what equalities
and inequalities like here I mean for
for convenience let's consider the
inequality kiss so I mean obviously my
everything polynomials okay so this is
what the polynomial optimization so an X
is n dimensional vector okay so but as
you can see this bang is a special case
of nonlinear program so that means Nani
apologies buddy brought some image a
nonlinear function subject to all kind
of questions so it's a special gift
nothing about but however since we have
a strong properties here so the
polynomial so we want the better we want
better conclusions so especially for
polynomial optimization we want some
kind of the problem to be served
acropole for example to find a global
minimizer's but of course well it's a
problem in Yee this charmese i me hard
actually is difficult so that it's what
i'd like to mention that me fun
polynomial optimization may also also
for non in a program to find the local
minimizer is still hard you study hard
so actually what I mean if your money
confess that many people they can be
excited windows ok I found a local min
Metazoa solving it looks like so about
however that is
is not true so to fund local minimizer
why I mean in commutation maybe
epicardium practice may be easier okay
Parcells vertically
yes directive code so what who saw
polynomial imitation watcher or by
messiah me whatever huge mmm
criminy Messrs further the the by like
most is the one that is reported by the
style that is called the moment SOS high
rocky o is called a lesser hello
otherwise the interpreter so it's so i
mean you took that means well you can
actually save the two versions away the
moment version finds the two versions a
sub of squares so so the basically you
how to represent a polynomial that is
man act here are a set that use for
example use pollution using positive
sentences all these another bands will
be me my freedom will come back safaris
be minimize the linear function over the
convex hull over the vector from
polynomials that is another version for
the moment version but interest in these
two versions am to what we each other so
same quote so that's why i usually all
for the moment as i was hierarchy and
for the moment i saw how we actually
mean has actual one nice properties the
first one is asymptotic convergence so
that means here we are simple harder is
the condition for the Archimedean
condition so that means the quadratic
module turn already passed is
constraining polynomials he's a comedian
and if this kind of semi the century to
require the feasible set is compact so
that is a blood that is Amira style
prude the same power conversion that
means be apprised sequence of
relaxations and each direction gives a
low point of the outcome value and
they're all bad converge to the true me
my value and the proper to use the
patinas pollution system is the
polynomial on appeal has a blah
presentation using sum of squares but
actually we're actually we have a finite
convergence actually that means why me
why you consider this as an awning a
program so we can write down the
optimality conditions we have a
first-order conditions
and second-order conditions so
understand for example second order
sufficiency conditions and thus truly
complementarity then this hierarchy the
moment a service hurry so we are come
with finally finitely many steps so that
means give the relaxation order is high
enough that then the problem is solved
exactly but here we assume with the STP
is seven exactly but if that's TB is not
something exactly then what we cannot do
anything there's no confusion so and
beyond this but I'd like to say that is
you usually I may to solve this
optimization usually we only apply the D
lecture what we can get a lot of pound
butt off all your life we we have you
should we have more interesting that
minimizes so the minimizes can also be
extracted
so that means can be actually is a
chunky the moment problem you can be
solved by singular value decomposition
Zandro Laskey and so but holidays also
has sub yeah I mean I mean what when we
talk about the polynomial name we must
make some reasonable subjects for
example in this case we need assume it's
the number of mini method is finite so
user gives a set of mini melodies the
infinities are added as if I'd give
Godhead
I don't know how to handle it so these
are the bondage actually well but of
course there's also some disadvantages
so the first one is as a commutation of
compacts the commutation expenses we
have it depends on the order said
relaxation order so the direction Y also
is adequate so when we apply
representation for the summer squares
below preventive services are adequate
so so that we call that new legislation
order so you buy usually yeah well we
applied the lowest order relaxation and
it works quite well but however so
radically to solve the home user via we
need the little X in order to be high I
mean why I mostly it depends on the
problems but the Salonika you can be
very hot so this is a commutation issue
another one is about the policy of
radical is that funny
so that is a discovered by Klaus
shredder he always have money amazingly
so he saw Hebrew that he's near the
foundation of the video of the piece of
a threat is three or higher okay so give
somebody so in this case then the always
exist some bad polynomial they obviously
extract some some polynomial some bad
points so that is this Heydrich we are
fair to have finally converging for
example we concept for the cubic a key
further me for the cubic case and for
the cubic damaging kids so minimize for
example minimize the [ __ ] polynomial
over the Union poor so it does not have
a finite convergence okay but how well
we if we use a software like crop report
you can either convert into steps so the
reason is a numerical issue it's a big
on using a Muslim polynomial to put it
off take me six but you fear and extract
the linear moment it is easy you
intended come to the neck do that very
easy but hava study done that is not
Mathematica sure okay so but in
numerically maybe we'd ever see that so
that's what okay so these are the I
would say yeah mean some the low sold on
you let's say you should is often tight
so he's actually is because most of time
it works well but how are you
all these kind of scenes neutered for
the the worst case that is hot okay now
what let me do it looks like the
polynomial ring is a bank we're actually
we're actually missing about actions
that is still a lot of issues that we
need to consider
so the first bad boy being total
conversions for example we needed a
comedic addition sounds a question
essentially it requires the feasible set
is compact so if the fears of there is
unbounded for example minimize the
polynomial in the unit have space how
can we do so by a semitone have
convergence so the nasa bang is well as
we observe such a computational cost it
depends heavily on the geek week so the
me answered elects such an order so so
these are usually what in the [ __ ]
computation we often want we need to try
our best to avoid high degree you'll
experience a wide that but there is
issue for fixed
relays
in order for them was the lowest what
what is the best UNIX aliens that we can
construct that is kind of an issue and
sorry I mean mr. Vladeck a lady we
cannot avoid but how are your pockets we
can't you we should try our best what is
the best way that we can do so also that
is by also also the nozzle vacancies
about the convergence so that means the
moment I saw a holidays actually you
proved to have fun and convergence if
there are some I mean this mystery is an
Archimedean condition okay plus some
optimality condition so especially about
that strictly complementarity or the
second order sufficiency conditions so
there means this condition out for money
planning program so if they are
satisfied okay we can prove they have a
final home on your hobby is that fair
that work having to so the question is
the third concern is the policy of
vertically so can we construct a new
hand rocky so I always have valid
conversions for all objectives so that
is I mean this way is a butterfly cursor
I mean is that you actually what the
topic of today actually is I'd like to
present some work about these three
issues well first let's review I mean
let's do the polynomial optimization so
let us say we consider first we concert
this at the general nonlinear program
okay we don't use any properties of
polynomials but we consider that there's
an on-ear problems unless I welcome you
so rehmannia programming if you take any
optimization course and you ever see
that is a KKT condition so what the
kicker is that music is quite a collage
one color condition so that means you
suppose we have a local minimizer okay
local minimizer new
sorry for we have for example the linear
independence constraint qualification
condition so is what I seek you see
there we have this then we have with
Lagrangian multipliers sorry buddies
that means the gradient of the objective
is the linear combination of the
gradient of the constraint functions
okay at the coefficient lambda lambda
bands rule and observe was like not too
much class and of course well you can
see if the constraint is active then
lambda
may be positive but if the action is in
activism is lambda must be
so they means the product must be zero
cells equal to the complementarity
condition and of course here was
inequality constraints than Lagrangian
multipliers are acquired to be
non-negative
okay you want to be non active part of
course if we have equation constant
lambda can be positive can be negative
okay it doesn't matter
so well here give the LIC Q say actually
this condition can be been candies quota
MF condition that means you can be
weakened party you set out by election a
breezy weather is different but holiday
different is not that much okay so you
say so that is recorded okay sodium is
notis others are me about based on from
Narnia problem soda so this is a no well
what for the active constituents give
the lambda R positive zombie Habibi said
you have a strict complementarity lambda
must be leo so you see I is a politician
academi done kill so I mean here you
steroids that suppose all the constants
are in active so that mean it's all CI
a-- positive so that means this we still
say sir covers astute how many manatee
holes
OUP have equation constituents the
lambda there is no signs that we still
say the strictly commitment honey so
super wrong because about inequality
constituents that are active so these so
these are quarter the mean the standard
vans from the done in your problem so
okay now let's see kgd condition
actually well you carry the condition
years sir I mean he's simple state so
you'll see so so what condition is solid
means these are the patient's okay so
you can see if X so for K the additional
row so you're saying if it was a body of
X is no it's given that who determines
the lambda that easy but that is easily
a problem actually but you want to find
lambda satisfy these equations applause
this man occupancies the linear program
or if for some anger say I see you see
so you just need to solve a linear
equation that's it so easy but however
yeah
we can do more actually yeah but how
mental you know your mom is a typical
document if we want to find X we don't
know the value of x because that's that
if Kody right so you can see what heavy
to actually thing is I should say is
that actually is a mathematical process
so easy suppose what we supposed I mean
a fancy Ida or given polynomial
functions para here we don't know X okay
not now the issue is we want to set the
case the person to coca me represent
Lagrangian multipliers in terms of X so
how do we Indian Herman like the lambda
in terms of the the kriti up 1x so okay
the question is but there exists a
polynomial P P 1 through p.m. so that
each lambda value was given and us p.m.
so that this man is true for all
critical points so if ax is not a pretty
planner of what we should for here
determinism that's not possible but how
easy well you can see you are CEO for
years in fact is giving you CDs my dizzy
pushing is linear in lambda so we can't
be mad nature to think what you feel in
your equation you're number one having
to we have diverse it what so we get the
rational representation that is
automatic and it's obvious true
so but how is the King here I mean he's
really I mean in commutation you
especially in optimization we don't like
much for me at all times unless you
don't find it is not a fun okay I want a
polynomial okay a polynomial so is the
easy you can can be expressed as a
polynomial functions over the creature
points so when you define is choose a
meager see that's a lot there are pick
advantage and you can see so first that
KKT conditions can be simplified for
example attorneys lambda is a proxy but
eliminate variables so that is ready by
advantage another why is we also can use
the sine condition so that means lambda
and manicure so that means we began we
imposed new conditions so in polynomial
time ization some more constituents the
better you'll be I mean in idea problems
that's bad but we won't last at last as
possible because you're not kind of that
your net case but however the important
know me about my Dania V nominee what
about that if they're more equation or
more constraint that's bad so we can
apply stronger lyrics Asians so that
so how do you actually that is actually
that is a password so how many do so
that means some so the main is that so
I'd like to please done is that so okay
so this is a ket so here is the first
conclusion is there always exists
polynomials so that the Lagrangian
multiplier can be expressed as a
polynomial function for all prettier
points but how about where sides are
free lunch being is not a subject the
option is very general saris so the
constraint polynomial is non-singular
I mean you make charm you people like it
not single Roger always I stay with that
actually but this is party is the body
Beavis option okay and working to of
course once we get that at least what is
that I which are party being okay so we
can we can remove my me for this
equation that we can remove lambda okay
and then we also give this new in
equality constraints and the important
ones we get more more consensus but we
can apply the moment as I was a
hierarchy we can get more that means
then we kept a that relaxation so that's
a basic idea so you probably know my
optimization okay we should never our
body about it more conscience the more
the better
okay how do we do that so I shaggy
Barclays we are observables this so okay
mommy's a Caidic addition can be
summarized as I see a single equation so
you pee while you suppose X is Alexis
give us a llama can be determine that
this equation you see the first values
are the you know is a part of the
comedian's but okay well yeah that
should be here is that we need to apply
our complimentary to condition so that
means you lambda you know it's a product
of the inequality constraints and London
is equal to 0 so we just put them
together so getting it anyway you get
these new matrix equal to CX
okay so CX so what is the first I'd like
to introduce that when you have non-sync
of ready not like I said I think you see
always a complex space okay to the point
so what signatures that means V
constancies
so that means this constraint opera is
non singular if the rank of this matrix
is used for rank so this one has m
columns and it has m plus and rows so
the number of rows is
always speakers as a number of columns
so Shiva is always equal to am sorry
sorry there's none singularity requires
the rank of this matrix is the equal to
M for all complex points so this means
that if you ever say actually this might
actually is equal to AI secrecy over the
complex space so what is that mean sighs
I mean you say suppose all for example
you suppose all the constraints are
active so that means the constraint you
find has a zero so tagging as I do
so when you three scales when is this
guy have full rank so that means the
radius of the constraining func
functions are being an independent
diagnosed non zeros it doesn't matter
because he's automatically Frank
suddenly so this way is the equivalent
to is the equivalent to the ICU Apsara
how about you
what yeah I would say you the stronger
than that ebuddy requires our the entire
complexes space okay so these are non
singular DT well we is non-sync ready so
how can we drop this stunt
it's a lambda so okay is that trick
sorry in size this is that made you can
see the seam is C matrix okay
so kud show you with a exists a matrix
polynomial ax so ax is a matrix
polynomial okay is a is non non rational
functions okay so that means y where X
is the block the universe of C so that
means you multiply air X in the left
I give me kemacite any matrix so if this
man is you them we are happy so what
while you say this is 3x times lambda
equals the gradient of that but you'll
multiply air from the left then is
canceled so you can return it so you see
the lab that gives can represent it as a
polynomial function over the critical
points so so how you do that that means
so that is well now the novices or
winters they exist so window they exist
a polynomial say that is a left inverse
of C so actually there is actually the
conclusion is very clear so this area
exist given out here for this the top
the top of the constraining polynomial
is non singular but the lancing batch of
why you'll see yeah just raise the break
basically
eh make sure you have it but - Nonnie
consists of polynomial equations then
you know is not sinking or that is so
difficult a change is a virtual medical
condition so and the proper G is not too
hard I said that if we apply positive
she understands it because it just said
because if because we know this this is
a is always for rank so that means if
you consider if we apply log attractions
and introductions for each time they
said the third column is that cannot
have common zero so that it's a master
that means that the constant one belongs
to that idea and if we can apply the
recursive it solids so now let's see
some examples so to say we consider the
have a cubical yes so have a cure sorry
defined by any quadratic inequalities
okay we have an exam we have this
actually see this is a see actually that
is a gradient I mean this year that
constrain your family and if you told
actually where this carries if you
multiply to be verified this one is a
tonic
I mean totally to remark that for to to
express lambda we do not need to know
two active set if you note we need to
know the actresses does not convenient
because we know we don't know what cut
consider active but here we don't need
one of that so linear constraints the a
consequence is is a similar but I'm is a
conclusion the same for the giver that
call the constraint functions are Lea's
and Bob Easton is this assumption see
this Canyon is non-singular
I mean this by what this is something
like that means if we consider the
polyhedron that means it requires about
Heejun is Manta generate what is always
a please condition you the stronger than
that because we require that we require
the non-virgin is always a compact space
but how what is the polyhedron you only
care about the vertex of the feasible
region so so you this guy Wow for the
linear case actually we can get stronger
conclusions that means is the area of I
mean under this assumption the air
actually obviously exists for how we can
pounds a decree we can power the
decrease our degrees and man is the rank
of a so what is amazing number of the
linear constraints so sorry if it's
about supplies yeah you should use that
is it gives a lot of linear constraints
that then is bad static we're happy so
these are the linear constant a similar
kind of voice I'm what we call as an
example this console has impacts
Samantha bees everybody to non-negative
summation is at most one okay
and for this is the C X and you can
verify these guys identity matrix when
you pair X is peaceful but how in this
case you'll see in this case amigos and
amigas and plus one so there's a
subtraction equals what so the degree is
what okay now let's do the optimization
so that it's so okay now here is a
one-party normalization okay we can now
here will be the subject being Reagan
sorry okay
the the constraining polynomial is
non-singular so that means what that but
order is that that they exist the air
acts that is from left okay that is air
that we can express lambda line in this
form okay what you need to be very
careful so when we minimize the
polynomial actually with a KKT condition
is not not Saturday
if the feasible set is unbounded so that
means the minimum values a you teen
radio is she may not be achiever
okay you know first a favor actually
measure this usually but you know given
on your program and the people don't
worry about this
so always assume it is that you that
Pearl Harbor for the polynomial
optimization give we don't know that is
this cutting user is about difficult but
yeah and you do assume it is the chip is
is not that you've oh I don't know I
mean he's supposed to be better had I
don't know he's so he cheaper than well
done that's easy then we can write down
to a KD condition okay recognition that
issue okay we write other means okay
these are the original constraints
she's our original all these that KKT
conditions shall return ignition we just
slowly be so as I envisioned in
polynomial Ramanujan we never worried
about more conscience the more the
better
now we are more be anymore because the
Bumi applied more that means we can get
a better lyrics Asians so we get it
because what I usually snogging three
says I mean if we there
singer than lambda can be expressed as
polynomials let me just just so he means
ever seen is a polynomial okay and then
we Twitter care and then we apply some
moment as I was hierarchy so we can do
so so these are the constraints actually
this is here I'd like to worry I can see
why some of you guys are bored with as I
was watching like irrespective presented
the moment aversion so no question that
means what you've linear lives obviously
okay you linearize polynomial this is
you have this and then you have a before
equations that we have equations okay we
have linear equation concerns for the
polynomial yeah inequalities that we
have localizing matrix to be positive
CST so these are the localize a matrix
I'm not sure I'd like to submit that it
has I mean is not a families so now what
is the direction that means what we if
you have more consequence I mean we just
applied so that is so what is that
converges well I'd like to change they
made a conclusion is that so I should
this is one less efficient so it was a
quadratic multi of the constantly is a
comedian then this sequence always have
finite convergence so that means week
but here that means pocket the subway
the the quadratic model of C's are
Kamini bah-bah-bah there is no
assumption about F okay Africa can be
our a very bad can be very good can that
can be how come you have for example
you'll be many many methods always tight
okay but so I should be here well you
got map why do we need the Archimedean
addition because the reason is because
here I don't use the preorder it you've
used to pre-order in this case something
can be removed
okay so that means UVU cancer here we
have several polynomial inequalities so
you've used a pre-order it so he that
use cross products among them but here
we I don't use that so that provides
that so that means I need that some
quadratic module to be a comedian but
how other cities can they can still be
weakened if I some actually I only for
example if we consider this the KD is
set for example security sorry of this
surprise Amir fine I tourism oh hi some
other properties amis then you can pop
that by his study is a clean condition
okay she's a clean condition
but how about this case something can
still be weakened and also I mean as
also there's another podium a here what
I mean is what because this is the
minimum body is not now how do we do how
do we know this bag is ID or not by
other means well we can apply flood
extension or floods truncation I mean
studies we considered the minimizer of
this kind of reapplied to consider as
the subsequence of Y and I give check
the run condition so there is the result
gives us given a set of minimizes is
finite then we are happy even studies is
not final found it
I wash it something can be me can do
this this Y is bounded yeah well you
just bounty this okay I should keep
hanging is a comedian if we consider
this as a set it's not a constant if you
assume these mines are convenient that
is good but here I make here that me
already and because this man is clean
okay using the only depends on seconds
the see but here you find here that
means depends on a few is not a very
fiber so funny yes you're right we don't
need define it so if this mine we
consider all the concentrate there also
constraining polynomials here gives a
quadratic model it's a comedian that's
the same conclusion too so there's the
same conclusion too but here then but
how about like that I mean that but the
thing is guys like it depends on us you
gotta check you another 45 so that is a
young application is not a convenient
party but however the cognition is body
creep so we only hit herself ways that
the constrain eponymous is a comedian
for example me minimize the polynomial I
was a hypercube
so you always a fine if you use this
hierarchy then you always have fun and
company so no matter the object is a
good or bad it doesn't matter
you know I was like a question why is
that yeah that is a simpatico no no I'm
not not sure that because of Shriner of
these that give that give the time I
know that's not you you guys did not
have a cape I don't know because that
name does not have any does is that man
so he's I would say in my city is hi the
spanner have a cube right I mean that is
that is what booty I don't that would it
be that would be could a booty answer
okay yeah you studies finally thing is
that mean Monica water has a groundwater
is that you'd obviously Chinese so this
is let me say this is I would say this
condition can be weakened about how this
is neat it only depends on their
constraints so now let's see some
examples so why would you say okay the
exam even if you are care for you me
choose a London polynomial s original
next thing is they're already tired so
that is not vanity Parker here I had a
choose some special polynomials okay so
this my is the difference is this is
maaske so this guy is what everything is
that the most important nominees has
implementing measures okay that's a
parasol that's what because I want to to
make sure he's detectable
so that's why I add this the color
Center okay that's a reason so that is
why me off have seen satisfied and two
e-tron's on USC the pound actually for
the cake was three or four the dirac say
I mean the you feet only because this
study is unbounded so this guy is
the merchants a classical moment that's
how the next thing is infeasible
what you mean nothing if he is on board
from below okay he's a Mormon but how he
goes five actually what is a new
medication I'm not sure he's really
infeasible not because it is very big
because of a new manager I cannot tell
but for this one looks like if we apply
the Lagrangian multiplier the it works
faster why I mean what pneumatically
well I kept seeing is the about
pneumatic because we can we don't know
that's we cannot be Sony exactly I mean
that is so you see what her actual is a
so this is one example so let's see
there is another one so this guy is
called as some seems like dropping some
polynomial but iid paste excise square
by X okay so that is so butter here this
is in an active I here is somewhat it's
a nonlinear constants I won't even
examine tell me more interesting so this
is at the end user or get just to it you
study exist the meaning of value of
EEOC's the comparison i mean for cake
was to over I stared cameras to there is
no advantage about when he was three is
big okay I did Emiko he goes three is
despite pneumatically okay so let's say
four equals three so this this value I
hope you see the bloody knickers a paper
about the survey of summer squares so
this polynomial is very interesting
action Vietnamese man active and it has
a lot of me - it has Rodman your you
have Y you for your interest in test
from performance on polynomial commands
in this one is very good
yes manicure Inez has a lot of me
mother's Anna Kiel I mean here I never I
added a coercive term here so I still
have this manual if I don't have this I
don't know maybe he's didn't finger many
I did nothing about it because this this
one in polynomial that tough and I just
read of course there's a feasible region
is non compact but how we have a
currency term here and if you just apply
it something Aliyev actually we have 11
me - well it's not somatic okay it's not
is not the mean it's a sort of me matter
is not somatic so you see a middle of it
there is not even a choice so you see
these are comparison so we have
well you've been mean if we don't use a
lambda okay Sam you have this you slum
does that encumbered you very quickly
sorry is it okay second man you go
reason I'm sure the time is also less is
that good less so it's really is as I
mentioned our game polynomial to
Malaysian we burn more constituents okay
the more the better
so actually determine even even if your
sees that combination of time actually
is plus give me add more constraints so
combination time is less not more so
okay let's see this one this one what is
this polynomial you see is also from the
cynics paper so this is is not so much
questioning is not like but not so much
question and wait for these constraints
on itself what we can verify the area
exist you can express it so we do it so
that you submit my body is a zero
actually but we can we can verify
exactly so but a hard you for numerical
performance we have this so you'll see
college of at first so funny receipts at
time
why is does not cost more you see you're
even less I mean but not to matter
because of while you have we still have
the polynomial okay now let's summarize
this so the conclusion is that so let me
sum it so lambda here the be immediate
that cutie isn't lambda okay we
expressed lambda as a polynomial
function okay over the critical parts
but holidays that subject so we assume
that constrains the the set of
constraint on gamma is non singular but
these are suffering is that you nautical
subject so it and use what wz the
expression we just do it okay we we get
more consequence as a new country we
have funny conversions under some
condition but as these conditions are
the see for example is the feasible
service queries are immediately is that
okay but not exactly does not know
I guess I assume oh okay you don't know
seconds on me okay okay saris are you
you are not happy about this
okay I get it I will give you enough
time sorry okay sorry it's a ok so he
says using expression because parking
yeah okay I'll die if I go so well I'd
like to mention that so that means the
construction user KD condition Giga
nationwide depends on the objective so
sometimes this is not easy but sometimes
it can be not convenient so that is also
at least funny I mean there is no
feeling okay science even by the saw
depends a user objective well but isn't
that we minimize something we should use
the observer you know if you don't use
the hard mu night but there's also
another argument so there is another
huge is what I'd like to mention that
actually I have as a manifest have son a
long time how to construct the Union
form as TP the subcommittee rome
optimization so we spend a lot actually
that is not possible
first by the by the bizarre of class
writer
sorry but I didn't even for the second
of non degree polynomials that is not
summer squares that says no as TB
representation so that means we cannot
be forgiven for that again we cannot
service of it but Hara
you be used up jerky there is possible
so that is anyway so that's it
[Applause]
thank you very much I think we have
enough time for questions let me try the
boring move method one more time being
European now I'm going to put my
European hat on and try some good
old-fashioned age discrimination
ok so anybody age 33 and under you can
ask this is chronological age you are
3,300 or you think you're 33 already one
question mind that you can ask I see
either one Takeda Oh dad that that
what's the definition of an Archimedean
quadratic module please define not a
comedian
not mean ha ha ha immediate ICC's a
comedian
so that means is we have say C CMD our
polynomials this car is a comedian if
there exists a polynomial P and
I mean all these guys are some squares
okay they exist the summer squirrels
Sigma 0 Sigma 1 Sigma so that so this
that is correct
that means that you exist one patina
type of representation size that the
finger inequality the single inequality
gives a compact set oh I mean the exact
equivalent condition oh this guy is
equivalent to this there exists some
scalar R minus the summation of squares
of excise belongs to run through the
patrolling module so that means this guy
is in other words saying is this sum
ours - sum minus the sum of squares of
exa that acam properties and in this way
44 and younger interested in asking a
question you said that this is only one
[Music]
for every objective does that say that
then the the semi algebraic set is a
projection of this vector Deidre no
because I know you see the contrast here
that means use the you look at the
Constituent here it depends on other so
then you see the hundreds that you see
yeah it's a Katy but so that means that
piece of a circuit depends on app so
that means that's why this is their
common cloud strategy I have trouble
using so it depends on observe the mean
mice construction depends on the
objective but forgiven
it said you know you you only need so
many polynomials to define that the
final product here that you can use
minimize here that you use it to
minimize them to minimize defines that
different that you need math money you
thought you only do care about a subset
of yet but well he's obviously this one
is only a sufficient inning he can be
Meegan but how is neat
so that is so the reason you for
important reason for using Archimedes is
that we don't use is a pre-order so that
means because we have me might have
suffering inequality constants so we
don't use that there's none use that
that means we need use a committee
condition but how actually so that
another version of the same idea nap is
done so that mean if we use if I allowed
you to use the play ordinance I mean
Sammy don't have a subject I mean that
we can remove this assumption
irrespective of chronological age
anybody's invited yes Tanya booty now
represented you can see the sum square
wait yes mighty condition yeah yes
but if I get that one name is the
advantage is that there is a why you
think he'll sings that yeah that's a a
uniform keep we pound for that but if
but if we use your noodle which not put
another representations there's no
uniform typically pound on that so
that's why we in the worst case we have
we have only asymptotic convergence so
that I mean notice a pullback either
I've known each other for example
minimizes the Muslim polynomial over the
Union pole it does not have a final
convergence sorry prove that a new
marketing just different now can you
marry you come right into steps
okay any elders
not then we'll thank the speaker again
[Music]
next talk is at 3:30